so Miranda I heard you had a very
specific favorite science subject as a
kid yes so when I was a kid I was super
into bugs which everyone thought was
weird when I was so weird I was obsessed
with bugs I loved doing experiments I
would always get you know the
butterflies how you watch them yeah go
from caterpillars yes metamorphosis yeah
this is my millipede I had a millipede
for five years no like you were really
into bugs into it yeah
Millie the millipede that is Millie oh
you should add another one Vanilli oh my
God oh my God that's amazing so wait I
you're younger you're too young for that
joke um I I hear that you're obsessed
with cats now right yes you can't have
that around your house then I'll eat if
animals I'm always trying to get them to
do animal segments on Mission
Unstoppable on The Science Show yeah
constantly I'm always like anything that
has to do with animals but um yeah I
love cats and I Foster cats and I
recently um when because it's been
raining a lot in La yeah I recently the
cat appeared on my porch in the rain and
I thought I was doing this great thing
by taking it to a rescue and then I
found out it had a microchip and lived
like a block from my house
yeah
back to the rescue
you pick up and like awkwardly bring it
back to its family
so I basically just stole you stole a
cat yeah that's incredible
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going